j'aimerais qu'on r viienne également sur
l'affaire Lina parce que Lina on va
rappeler déjà l'affaire c'était le 23
septembre dernier on va rappeler
l'affaire parceque on a tout suivi et il
y a des nouvelles révélations dans le
nouveau détective demain qui vont sortir
et on les a en exclusivité ce soir grâce
à Mimi allez-y bonsoir alors
effectivement le nouveau détective sort
alors tout d'abord j'aimerais qu'on
revienne sur l'affaire donc lina est une
jeune fille de 15 ans elle le 23
septembre elle quitte son domicile euh
dans un petit village qui s'appelle la
plaine elle doit se rendre à pied à la
gare à
saintteblaise la roche pour prendre son
train à 12h 2 12h3 rejoindre son petit
copain Tao or Tao on en a beaucoup parlé
ici sur ce plateau mais Tao n'a jamais
vu Lina arriver elle a donc disparu sur
le chemin entre son domicile et la gare
son téléphone portable s'est coupé à
11h22
elle elle a envoyé elle a eu le temps
d'envoyer quelques messages avant
notamment un selfie une petite vidéo et
depuis depuis c'est le flou artistique
complet on ne sait pas où elle est
l'enquête c'est un peu enlisée pendant
des mois et là d'un seul coup on
découvre quand même pas mal d'éléments
en tout cas le journaliste du nouveau
détective Christophe Guerra a fait un
travail absolument remarquable parce
qu'il il remonte sur quatre quatre
éléments
le premier élément très important c'est
la mort d'un jeune homme qui s'appelait
Benjamin ça c'est incroyable alors ça 22
ans alors c'est qui Benjamin c'est le
premier petit copain de Lina et ouais
qui est mort quand qui est mort 8 jours
après la disparition de de Lina ça c'est
ça c'est quand même ça c'est une info
incroyable g d'autr inf voir qu
l'affaire c'est fou et donc lui cétait
le premier c'est vraiment premier homme
de de la vie de cette de cette jeune
fille je rappelle qu'elle avait 15 ans
donc elle était quand même très jeune
c'est une lui avait 22 ans c'est une
histoire qui a duré 1 an environ et il
s'était séparé a priori en bon terme
environ 10 mois avant sa disparition
incroyable et le témoin qui a retrouvé
notre journaliste qui est d'ailleurs le
rédacteur en chef adjoint du journal euh
ce témoin et qui a accepté de témoigner
pour le nouveau détectif
a raconté plein de choses sur le sur ce
couple sur Lina sur Benjamin et en
réalité l'accident avait été signalé
dans la presse là je reviens sur ce ce
ce petit copain Benjamin Benjamin le 1er
octobre est flashé à 185 kmh sur une
route départementale ilmit 80 bon on n
pas là pour faire la morale bref il
passe à 185 kmh est flashé par les
gendarmes et quand les gendarmes se
lancent à sa poursuite il retrouent un
petit peu plus loin quelques kilomètres
plus loin la voiture littéralement
encastrée dans un rail de sécurité et le
jeune homme est mort c'est incroyable
est-ce qu'il aurait pu mettre fin à ses
jour bah alors il y a plusieurs
hypothèses c'est c'est le jour où il y a
eu une ouverture d'information h euh ça
veut dire que c'est à ce moment-là que
le magistrat instructeur a quasiment les
pleins pouvoirs judiciaire pour faire
évoluer l'enquête alors on peut imaginer
plusieurs choses tous ses proches et à
commencer par ce témoin sont persuadés
qu'il n'a rien à voir dans la
disparition de Lina bon on n'est pas
obligé de les croire bien sûr en tout
cas c'est ce qu'ils disent et a priori
la relation s'est bien passée c'était
bien passé ils se sont séparés en bon
terme cette jeune fille ce jeune témoin
qui est une jeune femme de 22 ans euh a
lu d'ailleurs des messages que c'est
Amielle hein c'est ça c'est sa cousine
c'est qui c'est sa cousine de Benjamin
d'accord le notre témoin c'est la
cousine de Benjamin qui était la
meilleure amie de Lina s'appelle comment
elle s'appelle Sandra Sandra c'est ça
voilà d'accord donc Sandra oui et donc
elle elle a fait ses révélations qui
sont quand même incroyables il y a quoi
d'autre comme révélation alors il y a on
s'est étonné que Lina fasse ce parcours
pédestre de son domicile à la gare or on
sait qu'elle avait une petite moto enfin
plutôt une mobylette hein c'est une 50
cm Cu et donc elleelle naviguait entre
son domicile et la gare avec cette
mobylette sauf que cette mobylette a été
volé au mois de juillet donc un mois et
demi avant sa disparition alors si on
est un peu tordu on peut imaginer que il
y a une préméditation ouais qu'on lui a
enlevé son moyen de transport pour la
rendre plus vulnérable c'est ça ouais et
à ce moment-l bah elle est obligé d'y
aller à pied et c'était plus facile de
la kidnapper sur le chemin alors que sur
sa Mobil C compliqué bien sûr bien sûr
après on a parlé de menace alors là on
s'éloigne un petit peu du du du cœur du
sujet mais il y a eu des menaces
c'est-à-dire
que 24 heur avant la disparition de Lina
on a vu Tao donc le petit copain de Lina
le nouveau petit copain de Lina on l'a
vu attendre pendant 3h devant la la
superérette où travaillait Lina et
évidemment des témoins l'ont rapporté
aux gendarmes donc les gendarmes sont se
sont intéressé à Tao savoir ce qu'il
faisait devant cette superérette pendant
pendant 3 He et en réalité d'après
Sandra toujours ce jour-là c'est Lina
qui avait demandé à Tao de venir un peu
à la rescouse parce que une collègue de
travail de de Lina était en difficulté
avec son petit copain qui voulait qu'il
qu' a harcelait donc c'est une sorte de
d'escorte enfin de de garde du corps et
donc a priori ça serait la raison pour
laquelle il se serait trouvé devant le
le petit magasin la superérette pendant
3 He 24 he avant sa disparition
donc et puis alors c'est ça et puis il y
a une
histoireout vieille histoire ça remonte
à 10 ans ou et là encore c'est Sandra
qui nous le révèle cette jeune femme
Sandra explique qu'il y a 10 ans un une
de ses amies avait été agressée
sexuellement elle avait été violée en
d'autres termes sur ce chemin sur cette
fameuse route départementale qui mène
donc de de la plaine à
Saint-Blaise le violeur avait été arrêté
c'est qui s'appelait Marc enfin son
prénom c'était Marc il a été condamné
pour les faits de d'agression sexuelle
de viol il a été remis en liberté depuis
évidemment les gendarmes se sont
intéressés à lui et il a pour tout à
Libye de dire qu'il était chez lui au
moment de la disparition de Lina donc ça
fait quand même quatre éléments h
donc pour résumer les pistes aujourd'hui
à 21h11 que cette affaire passionne
forcément et pour les téléspectateurs
qui nous rejoent qui sont nombreux sur
Lina alors les pistes c'est c'est quoi
après après après ce nouveau ce nouau
ces nouveaux éléments ce qu'il faut ce
qu'il faut comprendre maintenant pour
les enquêteurs c'est qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé le jour de l'accident le 1er
octobre pourquoi Benjamin roulait à 185
km/h de
Lina pourquoi il roule à 185 kmh sur une
route départementale pourquoi il a
refusé d'obtempérer quand les gendarmes
quand il a vu les gendarmes il a
accéléré et il est allé encore plus vite
et pour finir donc sa trajectoire dans
les conditions qu'on connaît euh est-ce
qu'il s'est suicidé ce jour-là est-ce
qu'il que c'est une semaine après la
disparution c'est 8 jours avant 8 jours
après pardon c'est ça on se dit oui
peut-être voilà euh ça peut être une
incroyable coïcidence mais euh bon he
euh ouais ouais ouais moi j'aime pas les
coïncidences ouais moi non plus Tao il
dit quoi parce que le le petit amis de
de de Lina est de moins en moins
soupçonné alors Tao a été effectivement
dans le dans le collimateur des
enquêteurs un bon moment faut dire
qu'il' il accumulait les maladresses
mais c'est normal il était nerveux aussi
le Pau on peut le comprendre tout fait
perd sa petite amie lui aussi il est il
est stressé a eu l'histoire du téléphone
qui avait perdu oui c'était c'était
quand même un petit peu un petit peu
bizarre un peu particulier et donc il a
il a fait l'objet quand même de de
vérification très serrée
euh ressort que a PR il y est pour rien
dans la disparition de Lina je crois
qu'on a établi formellement par la
vidéosurveillance et la téléphonie qu'il
était à Strasbourg et donc qui pouvait
pas être à deux endroits différents et
puis a priori il y a pas de mobile parce
que quand il y a un crime on cherche le
mobile Tao c'est une histoire qui
commençait c'est une histoire qui a
commencé au mois d'août il était le
cadeau d'anniversaire Tao en fait il se
connaissait depuis 4 ans par les réseaux
sociaux d'accord et il s'était jamais vu
physiquement c'est fou et pour
l'anniversaire de Lina sa maman donc
avait organisé une surprise elle avait
fait venir Tao non fort euh et pour
l'anniversaire donc le cadeau
d'anniversaire c'était ta donc a priori
il a pas vraiment de raison un mois
après de de supprimer cette jeune fille
dans dans ses conditions donc oui
Benjamin devient quelqu'un d'intéressant
pour l'enquête c'est que Benjamin donc
qui s'est suici qui s'est qui s'est qui
a fait un accident 8 jours après la
disparition de
c'est elle révèle aussi Sandra qui
c'était le premier garçon que Lina
présentait à sa mère c'était sa première
relation sérieuse donc c'est quelqu'un
qui a énormément compté pour elle ah bah
oui c'est le premier son premier amour
qui a quand même duré un an donc c'est
pas c'est pas rien 15 ans je rappelle
c'est vrai qu'elle dit qu'il s'était
quitté en bon terme parce qu'elle lu
avait montré aussi des messages de son
mais que apparemment tout allait bien
est-ce qu'il y a eu des c'est ce qu'on
se pose la question est-ce qu'il y a eu
des tensions entre Benjamin et Tao le
nouvel ami de de Lina ou pas du tout non
d'après notre témoin a priori non ils se
sont quittés en bon terme et je vous
rappelle quand même que c'était 10 mois
avant la disparition
donc on est en plus dans des tranches
d'âge 22 ans 15 ans bon ça vie revolte
un peu donc et puis c'est une relation
qui a duré qu'un an mais en même temps à
leur âge un an c'est c'est long et pour
répondre à votre question il y avait à
priori pas de tension entre Tao et et
Benjamin enfin je voudrais revenir sur
la dernière piste à 21h15 si vous nous
rejoignez c'est ce prédateur sexuel dans
le hameau de champené justement il y a
eu des vérifications de fait apparemment
il a pas d'alibi solide bah son seul
alibi c'est dire qu'il était chez lui
après en droit français faut faut la
charge de la preuve revient à
l'accusation hein
donc on est pas aux étatunis toutes ces
coincidence qui a autour de cette
affaire Tao qui perd son téléphone le
premier son premier petit ami le
deuxètit prier petit am Qui jours après
décède dans un accident derrière a un
prédateur sexuel dans leour c'est
incroyable il y a encore l'histoire y a
l'histoire aussi de Tao qui vient
protéger Lina parce que il y a une de
ses collg qui a des problèmes avec avec
son avec son petit ami qui ARS c'est fou
il y a tellement de pistes dans cette
histo exactement dans un tout petit
village merci en tout cas Michel d'avoir
été avec nous c'est vrai que l'enquête
avance mais c'est vrai que c'est très
long il y a plein de pistes on comprend
que les enqu
galère un peu merci tout de suite
western sur C8 merci à tous